[Music]
on this tuesday night new promises of
weapons to ukraine what nato and
non-nato countries are offering to help
ukraine defend itself we've got to move
at the speed of war as russia
intensifies shelling warns of world war
iii and the head of the un goes to the
kremlin plus we're on the ground in keys
with the head of ukraine's national
security delayed shot for kids as
covid19 infections rise among canadian
children what's the status of vaccines
and canada's joining the party it is
probably the best competitive experience
that isn't involving sport the song
contest that captivates millions in
europe prepares to cross the pond
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there are a number of developments we're
following tonight on russia's war in
ukraine the west is upping both military
assistance and rhetoric the u.s hosted
military officials from more than 40
countries today including canada at
ramstein air base in germany seeking to
accelerate the supply of weapons to
ukraine the u.s defense secretary lloyd
austin who said yesterday the goal is to
weaken russia today said vladimir putin
never imagined the world would rally
behind ukraine so swiftly and surely and
he pledged to move heaven and earth to
be sure ukraine defeats russia
but we don't have any time to waste
the briefings today laid out clearly why
the coming weeks will be
so crucial for ukraine
so we've got to move at the speed of war
and at the kremlin in moscow the u.n
secretary general met vladimir putin
antonio guterres across that long table
said he was there as a messenger of
peace
we'll have more on that encounter and
the outcome of the meeting of defense
ministers in germany in a moment but we
begin in ukraine with our europe bureau
chief crystal gamansing who has been
speaking to ukraine's head of defense
and security crystal
donna alexi danilov told me that foreign
intelligence predicted that russia would
capture ukraine within three weeks now
he says that victory is not yet in their
pockets but ukraine is proving to the
world that russia can be defeated
something he says no one thought
possible before february 24th
this bullet-riddled armored car belongs
to one of the most influential men in
ukraine
olexy danilov the country's national
security chief proudly showed global
news the image explaining that early on
in russia's war here everyone was
donating vehicles to the war effort at
least his had protection
we realized that there are big big
battles ahead
the ongoing fight for the east and south
of ukraine russia's intended target will
be intense says danilov
danilov doesn't hold back he calls
russian forces terrorists and says he's
bewildered by the fact that russia is
still a part of the g20 and has
permanent member status on the un
security council
how can you sit at a table with them
should we invite uh al-qaeda or
hezbollah as well let's also invite the
people who captured afghanistan
he says everyone knows russia plays by
its own rules
four times since the full invasion began
he has had to go to vladimir zelinski
and warn the president about possible
assassination attempts
his reaction is annoyed oh again he says
but i have to tell him whether or not
this war will become one of attrition
danilov says the west can help make that
decision by sending the right defensive
weapons in terms of the use of chemical
weapons or nuclear weapons by russia
that is a possibility and danilov says
they are working to stockpile medicines
such as iodine pills
donna all right crystal commencing in
kiev tonight thanks germany said today
it aims to find an alternative to
russian oil which it relies on heavily
within days and it's made a major shift
in its defense policy it is sending
anti-aircraft tanks to ukraine 50
gephard tanks armed with radar and
anti-aircraft cannons will be delivered
to the ukrainian military reversing a
long-standing policy of not sending
weapons to conflict zones germany had
said it would only provide humanitarian
aid and medical equipment there is more
detail too on canada's contribution and
the warning from russia's foreign
minister that the west is engaged in a
proxy war with his country that could
escalate into nuclear war abigail beeman
reports
nato defense ministers met at an
american air base in germany tuesday
discussing more weapons for ukraine
today
canada announced that it will send
ukraine eight armored vehicles canada's
defense minister says that contract was
just finalized and vehicles will be sent
as soon as possible we will continue to
not only send
weapons from the inventory of the
canadian armed forces but we are also
moving to enter into contracts
with defense suppliers
for
weaponry for ukraine
the u.s sending more aid to now up to
3.7 billion dollars ukraine clearly
believes that it can win
and so does everyone here that's quite
extraordinary that you the the nations
have come together that there are no
leakers
among the group it's very unlike the
iraq war where there was a lot of
dissent in fact more countries may be
trying to join nato finland and sweden
both with long-standing military
neutrality are mulling a bid to join
nato and as its members meet in germany
the united nations secretary general is
in russia
pushing for ceasefires and humanitarian
corridors out of mariupol i'm concerned
about the repeated reports the
violations of international humanitarian
and human rights law and possible war
crimes and they require
independent
investigation the u.n said russian
president vladimir putin agreed in
principle to allowing the u.n and red
cross help evacuate mario paul
russia's foreign minister raised the
specter of nuclear war on state tv
saying there are serious risks and
dangers it's unhelpful and dangerous the
rattlesavers
and speculate
about the use of uh nuclear weapons
a reminder of the stakes here an
unmistakable warning that russia is
still a nuclear power and that there is
always the possibility of escalation i
take it largely as the same sort of
distorted rhetoric that we've seen
coming out of the russian leadership
sergey lavrov also accused nato of being
engaged in a proxy war meanwhile
canada's defense minister will head here
to washington later this week where
she'll meet u.s defense secretary austin
abigail beeman global news washington
the number of people fleeing ukraine is
expected to double from the previous u.n
estimate the u.n refugee agency
estimates 8.3 million people will flee
ukraine this year europe's worst refugee
crisis since world war ii at this point
roughly 5.2 million people have fled the
country mostly women and children the
majority have gone to poland another 7.7
million people are displaced
within ukraine
and a final note on ukraine tonight a
symbol of severed friendship this statue
in central keeve was a gift from the
soviet union in 1982 as a symbol of the
relationship between russia and ukraine
the mayor of kiev says after two months
of war it's time to dismantle it
in ottawa tonight a rare special joint
committee of mps and senators is
reviewing the federal government's use
of the emergencies act last february at
the time ottawa said protesters blocking
borders and occupying the area around
parliament hill were causing canada
economic harm a global news analysis of
cross-border data shows that overall
trade was relatively unaffected by the
protests david aiken explains
when the ambassador bridge connecting
windsor and detroit was shut by
protesters canadians worried about a
huge economic hit the blockade of the
ambassador bridge has affected about
390 million dollars in trade each day
the blockade may have affected that
trade but it does not appear to have
stopped it cross-border trade data
recently released by statistics canada
shows that shippers found a way around
the blockade this graph shows the number
of ontario u.s truck crossings in
february and sure enough truck crossings
at the ambassador bridge ceased for the
six day long blockade but this line
shows truck crossings at all other
ontario usa crossings and it's clear
trucking operators quickly rerouted to
other bridges
what i was a little surprised by was
that we didn't see an effect even for
the perishable goods the um
you know food fresh food fresh
vegetables which was really an area of
concern as to the fears at the time that
the blockades would cause long-lasting
harm to the canada-us trading
relationship well this auto industry
analyst he's not concerned
us and canada are gonna remain strong
for for the near future at the very
least i mean again it's it's 30 years of
progress on integrating these supply
chains that's
i don't think going to be undone by by
one week on the ambassador bridge still
the public safety minister will make the
case that the blockades caused canadians
to suffer i would just really draw a
bright line between statistics and what
canadians were experienced
experiencing at the border to say
nothing of the fact that here in the
nation's capital the community here was
laid to siege as a result of the
occupation conservatives say the trade
data cannot be ignored i think it
undermines a lot of the government's
arguments in relation to the
justification for imposing the
emergencies act that trade data is going
to get lots of scrutiny and not just
from this special joint committee of mps
and senators but also from the judge
tasked with leading the public inquiry
into the emergencies act and that
inquiry gets underway later this year
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thank you the university once known as
ryerson is changing its name to toronto
metropolitan university the renaming
process began last year after protests
over the school's namesake edgerton
ryerson is considered one of the primary
architects of canada's residential
school system the university says the
new name reflects the school's location
in the heart of canada's largest and
most diverse city
there is more detail about the upcoming
visit to canada by prince charles and
his wife camilla next month they'll be
here from may 17th to 19th as part of
the queen's platinum jubilee clarence
house says they'll focus on learning
from indigenous peoples and on living
more sustainably they'll stop in st
john's newfoundland and labrador and
visit kitty vitti harbor
then travel to ottawa where they will
visit the national war memorial meet
members of ottawa's ukrainian community
and take part in a reception at rideau
hall and then it's off to the northwest
territories to meet community members in
yellowknife and visit the deta ice road
this will be the 19th visit to canada by
prince charles and camilla's fifth visit
the takeover of twitter coming up the
social media giant's uncertain future as
elon musk prepares to take charge whilst
the winds keep on coming for canada's
jeopardy champion
life on twitter is not real life but it
sure had a lot of people buzzing today
some users are looking forward to elon
musk's takeover and his promise of free
speech others are leaving the platform
fearing what a billionaire with complete
control will do with it mostly there's
uncertainty about what the future holds
for twitter as eric sorenson reports
like him or not no one can deny elon
musk thinks big but when he created
spacex and tesla the motivation seemed
clear-cut fly to mars build a better car
but twitter is something else musk says
he wants to promote free speech it's
important to the function of democracy
but democracy means power to the people
and musk's takeover of twitter means he
will have all the power to shape its
future it's going to be interesting to
see how he's going to balance tackling
the issue of like misinformation and
then also you know keeping freedom of
speech alive musk is a member of the
american civil liberties union but the
aclu sees a danger stating we should be
worried about any powerful central actor
having so much control over the
boundaries of our political speech
online
so will freer speech mean more
disinformation and hate speech this
stuff exists there now carmen celestini
studies hate and social media watching
the reaction on twitter she says some
are cheering musk some will quit the
platform but on balance it's a publicity
win for elon musk he's getting all of
this press and publicity people
returning some people leaving i think
that um we have to understand that
disinformation is going to exist and it
isn't something that one platform or one
individual can control twitter is used
by politicians newsmakers and the media
so it is influential but it's not the
most far-reaching social media facebook
has almost three billion monthly active
users twitter ranks 15th far behind the
likes of whatsapp and instagram beyond
the media and politicians it doesn't
have that much clout around the world it
has high profile cloud and that's a very
different thing which is why it's
valuable but it's not as big as people
think it is and that's what he's got to
work on is growing it many of the
biggest companies have turned themselves
into media giants apple tv amazon prime
and now musk with twitter the sales
pitch may be for free speech but it's
also business if you have access to
people's eyeballs whether it's facebook
uh instagram whatever you do have access
to people's dollars and their wallets
elon musk promises to bring greater
transparency to twitter many users are
just waiting to see clearly what he
plans to do with it eric sorensen global
news toronto
ahead the children who still can't get
vaccinated how can parents protect them
you're watching global national
[Music]
u.s vice president kamala harris has
tested positive for kovit 19. she says
she has no symptoms and she's grateful
to be vaccinated harris just returned
from a trip to california the white
house says she has not been in close
contact with president biden or with the
first lady
some of canada's pediatric hospitals are
reporting an increase in covid19
infections among children there is still
no vaccine approved for children under
the age of five as jamie morocco reports
physicians say parents have to find
other ways to keep their kids safe for
now
ottawa's children's hospital is facing a
double whammy staff are out sick with
omicron and two-thirds of kids coming
into hcr have coveted symptoms
so we're seeing specifically with this
wave is now increased emergency volumes
levels that we're typically seeing at
the height of viral seasons out of more
than 53 thousand cases of cobit reported
between april 10th and 16th countrywide
over 3 thousand almost 6 percent were
kids under 11. delays in data entry and
testing restrictions mean the actual
number is likely higher and recently
removed health measures such as masking
in schools and day cares aren't helping
we are in an enumerate way where
kids are getting infected like crazy and
there's no more restriction to try to
protect them mother julie la joie has
seen her children through two bouts of
covid while waiting on health canada to
authorize a pediatric vaccine for kids
under five and the regulator says it has
yet to receive any submissions from drug
makers the majority of kids have milder
illness but there are some kids that can
have significant illness and some kids
have long-term illness in march modern
reported its two-dose kid cove vaccine
was around 40 percent effective at
preventing infection the company says it
plans to file for emergency use
authorization in the u.s by the end of
this week but experts believe the fda
will want to see data on three doses
what they're looking for is to make sure
that if
this vaccine is indeed given to children
does it still work against the type of
coronavirus that's currently in
circulation pfizer says the results of
its three dose clinical trials will be
ready in the coming weeks what it
couldn't say was when it plans to ask
health canada to approve the shot for
parents the weight is infuriating that
vaccine is not there and now there's no
kind of
protection community level protection
that can help to protect them so
parents feel isolated for sure left to
fend for themselves and take precautions
on their own jamie rocker global news
toronto
next plans for a canadian remix of the
world's biggest song contest
[Music]
you will add
fifty five hundred dollars wow a tidy
sum today thirty two thousand seven
hundred dollars
well the good times keep rolling for
canadian mateo roach the 23 year old
jeopardy champion has won 15 games in a
row now
and has more than 352 000 u.s in the bag
that's the 10th highest amount in the
quiz show's regular season history and
the highest of any canadian competitor
well if you've ever watched the
eurovision song contest and millions
have you know what a spectacle sometimes
an outlandish one it can be it attracts
more viewers than the super bowl and
since 1956 international performers have
belted it out for the top prize now as
redmond shannon reports there are plans
for a canadian twist
when abba won the eurovision song
contest for sweden it propelled them
into super stardom every year nations
compete like this to see whose song is
the catchiest
although many countries simply aim to be
the craziest
it's as much about the look
as it is about the hook
how about a turkey in a shopping cart
or some ear splitting finish death metal
[Music]
these guys didn't win by the way it is
probably the best competitive experience
that isn't even involving sports but has
all these countries coming together
competing with music
it's inclusive it's fun big spectacle
and big audiences almost 200 million tv
viewers annually
countries can choose singers and
songwriters from anywhere celine dion
won representing switzerland in 1988 and
that was the most famous canadian
involvement until now eurovision canada
is launching to find a top tune from the
ten provinces and three territories we
have such incredible songwriters in all
of our our territories and provinces in
canada producers aim to capitalize on an
important part of eurovision's huge
appeal
the voting format means any underdog has
just as much chance as a big name or
voting bloc
we're being really aware of the fact
that some provinces in the country have
obviously a lot much larger population
but we want this to be a fair
competition so we're being we're looking
closely at how we do that
watch out ontario uconn is coming for
you and remember it pays to be a
friendly neighbor british performers
have routinely struggled to secure votes
since brexit redmond shannon global news
london
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm donna friesen tonight's here canada
is thunder bay ontario beautiful sunset
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]